[Music]
on this Sunday night China's peace plan
for Ukraine a ploy the skepticism and
Stern warning to Beijing if anybody has
potentially some influence on Russia it
might be China what happens if the
West's two biggest Rivals team up
Canada's anti-islamophobia
representative gets set to start from
new job let her do her work Calgary's
former mayor on the politics behind
Amira algowabi's rough road to day one
Ai and breast cancer the Canadian lab
using new tech to personalize treatment
I just looked at the pictures that I
couldn't believe that we're using
thousands for earthquake relief how this
Canadian 10 year old's name and birthday
inspired him to help
[Music]
global national with para Nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us in a few days the world will mark one
year since Russia's full-scale invasion
of Ukraine as Western Nations like
Canada continue to send military
supports to Kiev Washington is concerned
China could throw its might behind
Russia the U.S has warned of serious
consequences should that happen but as
Redmond Shannon reports China says it
wants to broker a peace plan rather than
escalate the war
the last week of the first year of the
full-scale war in Ukraine the country's
soldiers awaiting more Western tanks and
equipment on the battlefield there is
still a lot to be done we have to
increase our and accelerate our military
support to Ukraine as the eu's top
Diplomat rallies more support for Kiev
his U.S counterpart warns China against
supplying any arms to Russia we have
seen them Provide non-lethal support to
uh to Russia for use in Ukraine the
concern that we have now is based on
information we have that they're
considering providing lethal support and
we've made very clear to them that that
would cause a serious problem for us and
in our relationship amid the
ever-inflating tensions over alleged spy
balloons Anthony blinken met with
China's Foreign Affairs Chief at the
Munich security conference this weekend
telling Wang Yi that there would be
serious consequences should Beijing send
weapons to Vladimir Putin the Russian
economy is 10 times smaller than that of
China it's 13 times smaller that of the
us so you know China has the potential
to be a real game changer if it was to
support Russia but post-soviet expert
donakauin says potential U.S sanctions
could seriously hurt China's
export-driven economy if it comes to
that
ye told Munich delegates China is
opposed to profiting from the war he
says Beijing will instead propose a
peace plan as the first anniversary of
Russia's Invasion approaches if anybody
has potentially some influence on Russia
it it might be China but I don't think
we should overestimate the influence
that China has on Russia either he says
China would push for territorial
Integrity to be respected but Moscow now
regards five of Ukraine's 25 regions as
part of Russia before the war Vladimir
Putin and China's ji Jinping spoke of a
No Limits partnership but old
commitments would be tested if China
tries to broker a lasting peace Redmond
Shannon Global News London
another challenging obstacle stemming
from the war is the exports of grain
from Ukraine Ukraine's known as the
breadbasket of the world and the amount
of grain leaving the country has dropped
even after a U.N broker deal to keep the
supplies flowing inspection of ships
have fallen to half of what they were
four months ago and the backlog of
vessels has grown separate agreements to
keep supplies moving from the warring
nations are up for Renewal next month
but less grain out of Ukraine raises
concern about something else the impact
to Nations struggling with food
insecurity in Africa the Middle East and
Asia
and Global News will Air a special on
February 25th to Mark the one-year
anniversary since the full-scale Russian
invasion of Ukraine
for nearly two weeks the world has
watched as twin earthquakes shattered
the lives of millions in turkey and
Syria more than 46 thousand people were
killed many are still missing Millions
displaced and parts of the hardest hit
areas have been deemed uninhabitable as
rescue efforts come to a close there was
a moment of thanks for lives Rescuers
did manage to save
thank you
Crews from over 80 countries took part
in rescues even into the 13th day after
the Quake but as Mackenzie gray reports
despite the rare stories of hope there
is anger and despair especially over the
length of time it took to get
professional rescue crews into Syria
a thousand people used to live in this
block in Northern Syria 800 of them are
now dead Mustafa almawawari spent 22
hours under this Rubble with his wife
and three children he got Rescuers
attention
by banging on the debris
but while mustafa's immediate family
were rescued 20 of his relatives weren't
I have no hope left he says I sometimes
think it would have been better if I
stayed under the rubble
that grief and sense of desperation is
everywhere in Northern Syria where
thousands are struggling and without the
Necessities after the devastating
earthquakes and the decade of War
they've endured before
Syrian dictator Bashar al-assad has
limited foreign aid to the rebel held
North only Sunday were Doctors Without
Borders finally able to enter the
country 13 days after the disaster
the United Nations too has been Limited
in what they can provide we're doing our
best to step up the response as quickly
as we can
but those efforts simply can't meet the
demand as Aid workers have struggled to
keep up with making and providing tents
to the displaced many of those who were
now homeless across Syria and turkey are
still holding out hope family members
can be rescued from under what's left of
their homes and buildings but Sunday
also brought a grim Reality by Nightfall
the active search for survivors is set
to end across most of turkey those not
yet accounted for presumed dead as time
goes on there's no question that the
likelihood of finding survivors becomes
vanishingly small so it's a reasonable
um response I think
U.S Secretary of State Anthony blinken
toured the damage over turkey promising
a hundred million dollars in additional
aid for the region when you see the
extent of the damage the number of
buildings the number of Apartments the
number of homes
have been destroyed it's going to take a
massive effort to rebuild Canada has
pledged 20 million so far the funding
will help but for the survivors who lost
so much the cost of these earthquakes
are incalculable Mackenzie gray Global
News
Ottawa
thousands are missing in New Zealand
after a cyclone tour through parts of
the island nation last week
search and rescue efforts for survivors
are underway but disruptions to
communication and a lack of access to
damaged areas is causing delays more
than 28 thousand homes are still without
power the Prime Minister has said it's
the worst natural disaster there this
century and is keeping the country under
a state of emergency making the
situation worse Cyclone Gabrielle hit
New Zealand's North Island in just two
weeks after it was flooded with record
rainfall
at 98 former U.S President Jimmy Carter
is America's longest living leader in
American history but yesterday it was
announced that the former president
entered Hospice Care at his home in
Georgia after a series of short hospital
stays former the former president has
suffered recent health issues including
a fight with melanoma in a statement The
Carter Center says Jimmy Carter has
decided to spend his remaining time at
home with his family instead of
undergoing additional medical
intervention and he's grateful for all
the concerns shown by his admirers
Canada's first special representative on
combating islamophobia officially takes
office tomorrow but it has been a very
bumpy road to the new role for Amira
algowavi who's been under attack in
Quebec for weeks ironically for pointing
out islamophobia in the province at the
beginning of the month Al gawabi
apologized before her job began
and I would like to say that I am
extremely sorry for the way that my
words have carried how they have hurt
the people of Quebec
the words of concern relate to this
op-ed piece she co-wrote in 2019
referencing a poll that showed 88 of
quebecers who had negative views of
Islam also supported Bill 21. Quebec's
secularism law that prevents public
workers from wearing religious symbols
Al gawabi met with block quebecois
leader Eve Francois Blanchette and while
the Prime Minister says he supports
Serbia is demanded for her resignation
and that the position be abolished this
is a bad choice by the Prime Minister
who making such a choice kind of
destroyed the possible credibility of
the function
this past week former Calgary Mayhem
then she spoke to the senate committee
on human rights urging politicians to
stand up for Al gawabi he joins us now
from Calgary thank you for making the
time Nancy let's start with why it was
important for you to speak up
well thanks for having me Farah you know
when I saw the treatment of Amir Al
gawabi when I saw kind of the discourse
around the province of Quebec and
islamophobia and all of these things
when I saw frankly how she was being
brow beaten and lectured to and forced
to take meetings with people who had no
intention of listening to her were just
using her to score political points I
thought well the timing is apt to really
highlight how
we have a federal government but on the
one hand recognizes that we've got a big
problem in terms of the increase in
overall hate and Division in our
community and so on the one hand you
have a government that recognizes this
that appoints someone to fight
islamophobia but then on the other hand
sort of seems to expect that whoever
they appointed to fight islamophobia has
nothing to say about actual islamophobia
struck me is a bit odd what did you want
to hear from the Prime Minister and
other politicians when it came to El
gawabi and what happened
well I've been very vocal for many many
years around what was Bill 21 in Quebec
which is the law that restricts people
from jobs they can do if they happen to
be a Muslim woman who wears a hijab or a
Sikh who wears a turban or a Jewish
person who wears a skull Kappa keep a
yarmika I don't claim to be an expert at
all on Quebec not at all
but I do know that there's a general
rule which is that past discrimination
doesn't justify current discrimination
and I was surprised to see how many
politicians in Ottawa well you could see
behind their heads doing the math how
many Muslim voters am I going to
irritate versus how many other voters am
I going to get if I say these things and
you know what politically that doesn't
work at all what do you think the
government should do now with this
position
let her do her work uh you know make
sure that she's got a really clear
mandate in terms of what she needs to do
because the country demands no less of
it when we have you know young girls
physically attacked for wearing a hijab
at train stations in Edmonton when the
question of how do I express my faith
how do I dress becomes a political
question instead of a question of Faith
between my myself and and my worshiping
that's a real problem I really believe
that the issue of secularism has been
really mystifying secularism to me
doesn't mean kicking out certain people
of Faith from the Public Square it means
welcoming everyone and ensuring that our
community is strong enough that what
someone wears doesn't threaten our
culture it only enriches it it's not
going away anytime soon so what's the
way to kind of bridge the gap with with
these two sides
I've often suggested that I wanted to
see other governments in Canada
Municipal provincial Federal take a
stronger stance against Bill 21. let's
remember that it's not about secularism
and treating everyone equally if it
treats some people differently than
others and that's the other important
thing to remember this is not about
picking on people in Quebec
Studies have shown that that kind of law
would be broadly very popular across
Canada but most politicians say never
mind that it's popular it's not the
right thing to do and that's what we
have to be able to rely upon it actually
if you were a politician that's not
going to cause you votes people are
going to vote based on their taxes and
health care and education and all the
things that are important so pandering
because you think something's going to
be popular is not actually going to
change the votes that you get
all right Nancy thank you so much for
your time and your Insight as always
wait times reduced and quicker access to
care coming up how a Canadian developed
AI model could help cancer patients get
the chemo treatment they need
[Music]
artificial intelligence is making its
mark on many Industries including
medicine and the latest example of this
being an AI model that's been developed
by Canadian scientists for treating
breast cancer as Catherine Ward explains
it's capable of predicting the best way
to treat patients in ways technology
previously couldn't
it feels like something out of a dream
in terms of the impact I've been able to
make Amy Tai always knew she wanted to
help cancer patients her AI model is
exceeding expectations just a year into
its development the AI looks at a new
type of MRI scan in breast cancer
patients which is really tailored at
capturing details and properties of
cancer in a way that previous MRI
systems cannot capture the model then
Works to determine if chemotherapy would
be helpful prior to surgery one example
after another the AI learns and builds
its knowledge it's able to really
understand and then be able to predict
whether a particular patient based on
this MRI data is likely to benefit from
a certain type of chemotherapy the tool
was able to identify and predict which
patients would benefit from chemotherapy
with over 87 percent accuracy when it
reviewed a group of more than 250
patients in the United States a big help
for doctors who have traditionally read
those scans AI is always there as a
complementary tool or assistant to a
doctor to help them make better
decisions so they're able to treat more
patients as well as give them a better
quality level of care and patients
navigating treatment options so patients
especially cancer patients have very
limited time and they want to make sure
that they have the best possible
treatment because there's that
opportunity cost if you choose one type
of treatment that you lose the time and
the resources to do another type of
treatment Ty hopes this is only the
beginning so next steps would be like
expanding both in terms of breath and
depth so going to other canceled domains
potentially and then going focusing more
on the breast cancer in terms of how we
can leverage it for other types of
treatments other types of predictive
cases Catherine Ward Global News Toronto
oh recharged and renewed ahead the
Canadian company using old car batteries
to power its City's energy grid
[Music]
so there's a reason that museums and art
galleries have warning signs around
fragile pieces of Art and history and
it's because this can happen when you
don't follow the rules
a forty two thousand dollar dog
sculpture shattered to peace is it a VIP
art event in Miami this weekend after an
art collector accidentally tapped the
piece the iconic sculpture is from Jeff
kuhn's collection but it's not all bad
news the piece is covered by insurance
and there are prospective buyers
interested in the leftover shards
because quote it has a cool story
depending on where you live electric
cars may be a common sight to see on the
roads but what happens to those
batteries when they've lost some of
their juice as Krista Hesse reports a
Vancouver area startup has developed a
new device to give these old batteries a
second act and help power A Greener
future
this is the place where old electric car
batteries are given a new life these EV
batteries of 80 capacity left in them
once in each end of life so this makes
them perfect for stationary energy
storage applications gramesh sidhu is
one of the co-founders of moment energy
a startup hoping to harness the scraps
of the electric car Revolution to power
factories neighborhoods and even
charging stations
this large blue box is the company's
energy storage device it's made up of
retired EV batteries from Mercedes-Benz
and Nissan vehicles with more and more
electric cars on the road entrepreneurs
are hoping to turn a potential waste
problem into an opportunity for the
power sector the adoption of electric
vehicles causes major strain on the
utility grid so by adding a battery we
can provide Excess power to these sites
during the evenings when they're
charging all of these electric vehicles
it's an innovation that could save local
utilities a lot of money moment energy
is currently testing that out through a
project with Hydro Ottawa already it's
been used to replace diesel fuel
generators in remote areas and to store
energy from solar and wind farms
this technology is completely new
and even though questions remain about
its long-term reliability Canadian
Innovations like this get us one step
closer to a green Energy Future
Krista Hesse Global News
[Music]
Canada's kids step up next the
connections that Inspire these young
Canadians to help victims of the
earthquakes
[Music]
the seemingly endless stories of
heartache and loss from turkey and Syria
are overwhelming but they've also
inspired many people around the world to
help including right here in Canada and
as Heather urac's West explains some of
the greatest efforts have come from the
hearts and minds of kids
all right at 10 years old and a world
away he can't help search for survivors
or fly to the earthquake zone with badly
needed food and supplies
still is mirka Sam is doing what he can
to help the victims of this deadly
disaster raising money by running 100
kilometers over 10 days I turned 10.
that's why I'm doing 10 10ks
Izmir turned 10 on February 6th the same
day the earthquake shook turkey and
Syria I just looked at the picture so I
couldn't believe that people are running
away and the building just collapsed
like it was really heartbreaking the
Calgary boy has never been to Turkey or
Syria but he feels a connection to the
people there his parents named him after
one of turkey's largest cities
for Aisha Ali of Langley British
Columbia the connection is more personal
she has family in the earthquake zone
when I talk to them and connect with
them I feel sad for them because they're
like they have lost their houses and
their children and their like outside in
the coldness like even though it didn't
happen here but like I felt it happened
in front of my face Ali is one of
several students at Langley fundamental
middle and secondary school who were
Syrian refugees it's why they've spent
the last week fundraising for the people
there raising more than thirty five
hundred dollars so far in earthquake
relief
with at least one million people
suddenly homeless in turkey and Syria
the need for urgent aid is great and of
course Canada's young people aren't the
only ones anxious to help we haven't set
a goal but if we were to set a goal it
would probably be somewhere in the range
of 10 to 15 000 from the event this week
is Sam is hoping to raise ten thousand
dollars as well in the face of such
overwhelming Devastation Canadians of
all ages taking steps to help in any way
they can Heather York's West Global News
Calgary
and I just checked online Izmir is just
about a thousand dollars shy of his ten
thousand dollar goal and by the way he
also ran a half marathon to support
girls in Afghanistan we have some
amazing young people in this country
that's global national for this Sunday
night I'm Farah Nasser tonight's your
Canada is the ice sculptures at ottawa's
winterlude Festival we love senior
Canada so please keep emailing us those
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and take care of each other good night
thank you
foreign